ci sta
un po sta dormendo non svegliarla
il mio libro storie paurose a scola di
misteri e ora disponibile per il pre
ordine su amazon preordina l'ho subito
meno design a sparare ci proveremo altre
mode giovanni guardia
thomas liz varie volte oggi siamo
abbinati
evitare che
il mio cerchio si abbina abbiamo un po
vero dopo un po di oggi chiusi visti
oggi riproveremo 2 di mons come sempre
se questo video sistemi la mi piace
troveremo altre bozze quindi spolli
soleggiato slanciato e se non avete
visto le scorse mode dove avete reso con
questo perché sono bellissima anzi
scriveteci pure la vostra preferita nei
commenti la prima mode è questa si
tradisce un eremo e in a global anche
world non scappava da diego dimostreremo
che funzioni perché sapete che c'è stato
un file in una delle mode che aveva
trovato precedentemente anzi scrivetemi
commesse sapete qual è ma ci sono stati
vari errori vari bug e non ha funzionato
molto bene però cose la volta dovrebbe
funzionare e cioè invece del grappa the
normale dovremmo prendere le mani biaggi
weik vediamo se funziona anche perché
poi sarà bello interagire con attigua di
coleman in
un altro modo siccome noi saremo a
khimki l'altro mondo sarà un altro
personaggio più scoprire questa ragazza
ecco il grappa che eccolo e vorrebbero
vediamo se funziona non è qualcosa
di bello di addio guardi vediamo
[Musica]
solo una mano ora so perché l'altra
dobbiamo prenderla per karina
funzioneranno ancora questi derby per
lui la mano di archiviati apparentemente
funziona ma rimasti bloccati nel gioco
ok scoprirete chi è l'altro personaggio
cartoon cras
che carino no no è molto inquietante
precari non vendiamo kitchen venerdì
quando vediamo le scatole allora questa
scalda sono girate e carte un cartello
studenti e non credo si veda molto
sembrano chiuse proviamo a capovolgere
una delle scale
non si veda accendi la luce o che si
tratti un cazzo cazzo cazzo
come baby è scappato un calcio che devo
fare
vediamo questo invece a chi sei qui
questo è scappato
prendono a calci piano piano che fattore
alzi e non si vede troppo buio forse è
la cartolina mia cartoon che dentro e
qui invece vediamo si siano gli occhi
qualche vano grande che a guardare la
palla non la mano del parto un piatto
gigante guarda
[Applauso]
guardate comunque ci spostiamo perché a
carlton cat.c guardi medici sta seguendo
con gli occhi e prodotto andare
dall'altro lato vediamo da dietro
sembra che abbia la testa vuota basi
nella terra no forse l'ombra per fortuna
adesso non si muove perché non abbiamo
ancora attivato nell'elettricità ma tra
poco lo vedremo anche i movimenti ci sta
guardando lo è
anche adesso ci sta guardando vedi ma
anche se ci spostiamo quasi guarda bene
arriviamo l'elettricista e vediamo
magari staremo più veloci e scappare dal
cartoon ghetto perché siamo adeguati e
manuel un gatto i cattivoni veloci
beh però magari noi essendo di nuovi
cartoon cat avrà paura di noi quindi
magari però
caffè
vediamo se questa volta riusciamo a
finire il giappone dovrebbero esserci le
chiavi vediamo a miccoli chiavi auto
brega ripresa prende cosa fanno gli
archi
scappiamo e rafa era lui mai visto
scappare ma era aperto un caso antigua
una mera cartuccia e
bassi ma di non aprire lo sportello
come possibile o no
no
no no
guarda possa attraverso allora va aperta
la porta perché altrimenti non funziona
ok per fortuna una volta caso adesso che
l'elettricità attiva vediamo se ben
disegnati da veti hanno cambiato le
scatole l'eros è scritto ben di no c'è
scritto mercato
[Applauso]
ma che cazzo migliano cartoon kateb rei
di sono tutti e due bianchi e neri lo
stile vediamo la mano vediamo la mano ma
c'è qualcosa ma sembra che la voglia di
a chi vuoi chi normale si è quello che a
chi 400 fra quanto bianco che strane va
bene abbiamo preso noi del conto giallo
sta per arrivare alla mano vediamo se è
la mano di aghi vaghi o se la mano
normale
da qui sembra sembra normale però non è
rotta
che strano vediamo
sembrano amano blu sì sì non è possibile
che sia la mano nella mano blu come la
mano blu vediamo se si trasformano
lavoro di a chi vuoi forse è la mano di
attivata sì è proprio quella
andiamo ad aprire porte yo yo chiediamo
a chi è bello essere anche i fuochi
speriamo di riuscire a spaventare
cartoon castelsecco stiamo andando verso
la fabbrica dei giocattoli
o che è successo hai visto sarah un bug
che ci ha fatto uscire per un momento
fuori dalla fabbrica ora
tornate indietro e fermati quel momento
è riuscire a vedere cosa si ma cosa c'è
fuori dalla fabbrica se abbiamo sopra ad
attivare all'elettricità e poi
finalmente vedremo cartoon cat vediamo
se si insegue lo stesso anche se siamo
anche i walkie ok ora possiamo attivare
la fabbrica abbiamo attivato
l'elettricità attivi o meno pop
si va da via casalese vediamo che il
giocatore diverso questa volta come
intendi offre solito cuba stone
sembra ok vennero passati
vediamo vediamo cosa assembla no forse
adesso manca un po di colore vedremo se
lo colora
eccolo qua nel set d a chi fuochi il
peluche
come un po diverso forza effetti tutto
festa tv areali
pronti di fronte a prendere un rimpasto
agendo carte un cazzo allora sta
analizzando a posto anzi dovrei arrivare
kat kut
futuro ma ora
eccolo
aiuto è brutto e ancora più paura per le
malattie frugoni siamo abbiamo subito a
proposito di cose paurose avete
preordinate al mio nuovo libro storie
paolo della scuola di misseri se non
avete ancora preordinato cliccate nel
link
così riceverete soprip rivestitelo
preordinano una cartolina autografata da
me e
vi piacerà tantissimo vedrete vi lascerà
qualche
dicevo prima per le labitalia questo
preso ha fatto in casa queste storie vi
lasceranno col fiato sospeso e i quattro
protagonisti di affezione rete
tantissimo ai quattro protagonisti
vediamo se evitare il gela parare in
opera vediamo siamo riusciti forse
non dovevo andare di no così vogliamo
scendere a londra di dare forse ce la
fai charlotte sapore da curtu che
comunque carlton carte non ho proprio
paura a dire di walking noi siamo
animali ma la carta un caso ebrea
si vedevano solo
al buio ora provo io io però voglio
provare a careca toccato con le mani da
jim oggi magari gli fa paura poi siamo
andati ormai vai di un cazzo cazzo bagni
a era mio dono di luoghi dovresti avere
paura di me perché mi sono più grande
nel frattempo che vitale riprova io vi
do qualche spoiler sul libro di
informazione perché mi aveva detto che
in ogni video gli avrei dato qualche
spoiler o la storia se un libro infatti
se non avete visto gli altri video
andate poi a vederli perché scoprire era
entrato di cose allora che poi il porto
d'armi oggi vi spoiler o un'altra delle
creature è un'altra delle creature la
sirena
ci siamo quasi
oh no ono non era la strada forse era di
qua
per diventare di qua e un amico ma vabbè
per gennaio
corri corridoni
voglio sto correndo piccola tifosi
bisogna buttar di la scatola in testa
si è
ricordato lo
hai fatto cadere siete un cazzo sì
c'è una macchia
proviamo andare avanti se riusciamo a
vedere nuovamente la bambola aiutiamo vi
dobbiamo entrambi internet i ore vi
ricordate fuori da c'era forse c'è
un'altra cassetta bisogna stare attenti
che non si creda che abbiamo riusciti a
buttare giù
allora qui c'è il fiore che c'è qualcosa
mentre in quella porta un padre questa è
l'ultima carezza
chievo l'ultima cassetto e poi entriamo
e vediamo se c'è ancora la bambola pop o
forse c'è qualcos'altro
certo cazzo
non lo so ben o carlton catena mio
moschin per l'eroe spero
andiamo via b quali sono stati i pupazzi
appesi c'è scritto andatevi a top scarpa
curioso e non è invece creiamo mia gente
ok abbiamo cosa ci sarà adesso sembra
uguale la stanza di poppi
ma sembra tutto tranquillo sembra un
corridoio normalissima marittimo ha più
paura questa forma di
operatori vediamo vediamo chi sia chi
c'era prima volta ero più avanti forse
quindi si chiama della bambola apriamo
di lei
apriti
ecco le firme troppo più a dormendo non
svegliarla ma
non diciamo perché noi
come penso che abbiamo fatto una brutta
fine
e stato un bel mi piace però vi lasciamo
papa tanto di cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video linkato su quella che
preferite che volevi dire ciao ciao